starwars the bad [ __ ] we're gonna watch
emergency awesomes breakdown video today
Luther characters in the Clone Wars
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie big news they've just
announced a new Star Wars series that's
gonna premiere next year big surprise so
I'll explain what's going on where it's
gonna take place the characters that are
the timeline with the Mandalorian season
- the obi-wan Kenobi series the rumored
series and all the other upcoming shows
that Star Wars is making for Disney Plus
of course we'll do some episode video
support when it does drop so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos coming up really
soon in a couple of months anyway number
these and talk about the easter eggs we
go along just to keep things organized
but big stuff first
the series is literally called the bad
batch so it will follow plum force 99
after the events of the Clone Wars on
immediately after the events of the
Clone Wars so it also takes place after
the events of the Clone Wars finale with
that time jump season 7 episode 12
anakin skywalker having fully become
Darth Vader and come to look for sokka's
ship with more of the clones and just
found the wreckage with her lightsaber
that she loved that's got spoiled for me
already cross here now echo the club
that they rescued during that first part
of the Clone Wars season 7 now that
makes sense why they spent so much time
with the bad batch at the beginning of
the season because they knew that they
were gonna do a spin-off series set
around them during this period of the
galaxy right after order 66 in the end
of the Clone Wars so just to be clear
when they say it takes place after the
Clone Wars this takes place way after
order 66 order 66 happens then a little
while later the Clone Wars ends so it
takes place before the events of a new
hope also before the events of the Star
Wars obi-wan series
before the rumored events that the Star
Wars for soca series they haven't really
said when that's gonna take place in the
timeline but it's supposed to be Rosario
Dawson's version of a soca it has to
take place sometime either after star
wars rebels or after the Star Wars
obi-wan series since it takes place
right after a lot of what's happening
right here a lot of the other Star Wars
Clone Wars characters will pop up who
survive the end of the war and order 66
in terms of the other clones so you have
ahsoka obviously in wrecks because they
totally made it out Rex also showed up
on Star Wars rebels is an older version
of Rex they also revealed in real life
as the event of the Mandalorian season
to 10 where a Morrison is going to be
can do we as Boba Fett because Boba Fett
is a clone of his son where Morrison
will also eventually show up on the
Mandalorian as the live-action version
of Rex two will also probably see more
Darth Vader more emperor more Imperials
so rebuilding his criminal power base
with a shadow collective in crimson dawn
before the events of solo of Star Wars
story that post-credit scene so it's
also probably safe to say that the
series will take place before solo a
Star Wars story there were also some
very young versions of Star Wars rebels
characters in the final Clone Wars
episodes like Kanan so older versions of
those characters might also show up who
aren't quite as old as they are when we
get to Star Wars rebels Kanan just being
the best example because we know he's
confirmed at the end of the Clone Wars
it's brand-new assuming that nothing
goes wrong they'll probably try to get
at least four to five seasons with
around 10 to 13 episodes per season
similar to run to the Clone Wars season
seven not a ton of episodes but it's
Dave baloney he has total creative
control he's executive producing your
show running so it should be pretty
solid but they haven't any because Star
Wars Celebration was canceled later this
year because of the virus they would
have shown us some sort of a teaser at
that because if the series is ready to
premiere next year they're probably
pretty far along with animation of
production because it's just a teaser
announcement they didn't reveal the
official release date by next summer if
not by next spring what I'm hoping is
the animation will be just as quality as
the final arc of Clone Wars that is a
high benchmarked extent though it was
kind of a special case because you could
tell us where they spent most of their
budget because it was kind of like a
movie just broken into four parts the
whole reason they use the special intros
for those final Clone Wars episodes were
because they were intended to cross over
with Revenge of the Sith and give you
all the moments from that movie all the
story turn to the dark side being
anointed as Darth Vader and of course
order 66 probably the most important
event in the clones lives next to the
actual war itself and revealing the
final fate of Darth Maul because there's
so much dark mole that shows up later in
the timeline surprisingly hard to kill
very hard to kill Dave Filoni himself is
also still an executive producer on the
Mandalorian series let's stay on that
for a while a lot of people feel like
eventually if things go well he will
eventually take over star he's becoming
the Kevin five years that's not entirely
true
really big programming coming up some
really cool stuff if you didn't see it
probably one of the best date baloney
clips of all time talking about Star
Wars came out of the Mandalorian so this
is him fades fighting zone app to the
Star Wars story in what Star Wars itself
does make you appreciate it a lot more
this does really tell the story that
we've all grown up with imagining who
Anakin Skywalker was in Phantom Menace
you're watching these two Jedi and
they're kind of like this evil villain
Maul couldn't be more obvious in the
villain villain he's designed to look
evil and he is evil and he just
expressed that from his face all the way
up the technical fights with what's at
stake is really how Anakin is going to
turn out because quad mount is different
than the rest of the Jedi you get that
in the movie and qui gonn is fighting
because he knows he's the father that he
needs because qui gonn hasn't given up
on the fact that Jedi are supposed to
actually care and love and that that's
not a bad thing the rest of the Jedi are
so detached and that become so political
that they've really lost their way and
you know starts to see that in the
second film but quaggan is ahead of them
all that's why he's not part of the
council so he's fighting for engines and
that's why it's the dual of the face the
fate of this child and depending on how
this fight goes Anakin has been in his
life's gonna be dramatically different
so quite a lose of course
and he's left with obi-wan but we want
trains Anakin
at first out of a promise he makes a qui
gonn not because he cares about him when
they get Banneker but they find my dad
leanings why do I feel like we've found
another useless life form he's comparing
Anakin to Jar Jar and he's saying this
is a waste of our time
why are we doing this why do you see
importance in these creatures like Jar
Jar Binks in this ten-year-old boy this
is useless so he's a brother Tanika
eventually but he's not a father finger
that's that's a failing for Anakin he
doesn't have the the family that he
needs he loses his mother in the next
film he fails on this promise that he
made mother I will come back and save
you this is why the three couples rock
ultimately my favorite Star Wars so that
moment in that movie which is a lot of
people I think diminishes it's all just
a cool lightsaber fight but it's
everything that the entire three films
of the prequels hangs off is that one
particular fight in the mall serves his
purpose and at that point died before
they bring it back but he died and
that's shown you again on the Emperor
it's completely self-serving it doesn't
catch you some tool that he's using
people and I was gonna use this child
that follows all the way through to the
line which terrifies music it when the
Emperor tells Luke you like your father
arm my Star Wars he totally gets Star
Wars that's why anytime he works on a
series like the Mandalorian or any of
his animation I always get really
excited but Kathleen Kennedy in that
conversation yeah Wars rebels resistance
I'll have a different animation right
now but I'll do more videos for the
series when they start releasing some
more footage there were a couple of yep
just drops
videos with that and I'll do more
mandalorian season 2 videos when we get
more information about that everyone
click here for all my Mandalorian season
2 teaser trailer videos and click here
for my brand new Mandalorian of baby
Yoda video thank you so much for
watching everyone Stacy dope dope some
things to digest here man I've been
watching the Clone Wars in chronological
order I only got like a hundred
something episodes left but I'm doing
pretty good all things considered
playing a lot of catch up on everything
catch up with Clone Wars then some other
TV shows and some video games that's
I've been taking advantage of a lot of
things being delayed I've been enjoying
Clone Wars a lot yeah unfortunately
there's some of the final moments of the
series to get ruined for me but that
hasn't taken away any of my experience
that I've been having with the show so
far don't know if I'll get around to
rebels the the goal ideally was to
finish all the Clone Wars before
Mandalorian season two comes out the way
how the Mandalorian season 1 ended I'm
like if it seems like it's pretty vital
that I watch Clone Wars to really get
the full lore and experience of it all I
don't know how Star Wars fans are
reacting in this though I don't know if
they're super excited about it or not
for those who are invested in the Clone
Wars because it seems like right now
what they've been doing with Star Wars
is filling in a whole bunch of
quote-unquote gaps some of them might be
necessary some that might not be
necessary
one thing that studios are really doing
a lot more now and it makes sense that
they did now it's an animated show is
that because of the times of Kovach a
lot of studios are looking way more at
animated shows more than anything else
you can successfully develop this it's
not ideal but you can still develop an
animated show from people working at
home including voice actors included
this announcement of them doing an
animated series there's no surprise just
kind of curious to know if like for the
guys who you have watched the Clone Wars
would you be excited by this loved rogue
one and uh that's not them everyone's
favorite Star Wars movie but I love that
movie this feels like it could be a
little bit more on the nitty-gritty side
with their animated series the fact that
you'd be following the bad batch and not
you know ahsoka tano
her like the Jedi per say but these
troops you know I think there would be a
really cool badass tale told Amelie tell
ya I mean it seems like a nice
opportunity and they said in the press
release that they want to use this as an
opportunity to bring in new fans and
diehard fans like so I wonder too with
the time and place of this and I don't
know how big ko fit factored in but
because you know the mandalorian is
easily the most successful thing Star
Wars is going right now and then you
have the Clone Wars wrapping up and all
that makes a lot of sense I think at
least from an outsider's perspective
that they would want to go with
something that has that mercenary vibe
but that also connects directly to one
of the most popular pieces of Shor's
lore at work right now thinking just
nuts and bolts I mean that one episode
of the Mandalorian I kind of flash to or
they do that at the Bill burr episode
where they have the little group they're
going in to do this breakout and I'm
thinking like that's kind of the vibe I
would imagine because you've got this
team each one has their own specialized
power you know that makes them special
from all the other clones and what not
say that seems like you know something
that would give you fertile ground to
get a lot of really cool you know
espionage mercenary action but also
easily expanding or dissecting you know
kind of converging with other parts of
the lore so that we can kind of see it
from again an outsider's perspective so
it seems like there's a lot of potential
I could see the initial reaction to here
in this announcement I can see a
potential divide half the people
probably be really excited about it and
half the people might be like let's move
on to a different thing with in Star
Wars now because this is another part of
like the same timeline in between a new
hope and the prequels you know it's
still in that timeline I give it a
chance
especially because Dave Fallone is
behind it like that clip that I did see
when a like they had the documentary on
Disney Plus but I did watch that clip
many weeks ago what's powerful about
that clip even if you don't like the
prequels like I really don't like the
Phantom Menace it's the only one I can't
stand but that clip of him explaining it
that alone is powerful enough because it
shows you the amount of knowledge Lord
that he really understands within Star
Wars
any argument that I hear about giving
over the reins to a felonious entually
is doing already in the TV market he's
involve a Mandalorian clone where all
that all the show is bad backs now
included you might as well give over the
reins
the guy because he really knows it
granted I don't know how he would be
with just solo individual live-action
movies per se but in terms of at least
being involved as a creative spearhead
creative producer in the films somebody
bringing on other creatives yeah well he
seems like the perfect fit I don't know
why this hasn't happened yet when vans
are so behind it George Lucas obviously
is behind it listen to that clip again
I'm like I mean he just really makes me
appreciate it yeah I have a sneaking
suspicion that once Kathleen Kennedy's
contract is up we may very well get what
all this because yeah Dave Filoni does
seem like the through line that equals
the good Star Wars yeah and the reports
a Mandalorian season 2 is complete I
don't know how much of all I can say we
might do videos on uncertain leaks that
come out or reports but I'm not one to
divulge if I happen to know someone
involved and I don't want to give it I
don't want to get anyone in trouble I
don't believe the Mandalorian season 2
is done filming and I believe it's on
halts right now the rest of the film
I can almost a hundred percent confirm
this and I don't want to say anything
too specific right now you might know
what I'm referring to I think we'll be
getting the Mandalorian season too much
later than Raw will well probably look
at a trailer but I don't think we'll get
the actual show for I think it's gonna
get pushed as well which is a bummer but
we're living in strange times right now
and who knows maybe we'll have some
animation to cheer us up if we have to
wait extra long yeah exactly I hope I
don't need to have to squeeze in rebels
also to appreciate the bad batch it
seems like to really appreciate rebels
you have to watch Clone Wars I don't
know how accurate that is feel free to
correct me in the comments know what
they're doing with the bad batch
incinerated be like a brand new show for
Disney Plus they wouldn't want people to
feel like they have to watch the other
shows to get it even though they these
characters originate from the Clone Wars
I'm getting the vibe that you don't need
to necessarily watch all of that show it
might be 20 minute episodes that's a lot
of episodes all right it is a lot anyway
guys you excited for the bad batch leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
phoner forgot a youtube video last but
not least is to up David Gandy David
Gannon ater a man who would before
everyone was telling me gettin on my ass
about not watching Clone Wars and rebels
the first man to ever do that was Sir
David Gandy I know that you've been
going through a rather rough patch
lately
it seems like for the most part that
you've been finding a way to find
creative releases to be able to be on a
better path and even a little bit more
self discovering right now which i think
is a beautiful thing I hope that amidst
all the chaos and other personal eye
things you've been having to deal with
that by the end of 2020 you're able to
find a great positive outcome out of
this because it seems like you're headed
down that path and honestly when I read
some of the messages that you send me I
find it pretty inspiring so David thank
you for being you and I love you buddy
hope to see you again soon once all this
craziness goes away especially
considering that California is
officially in lockdown again as it's a
day